the girag and experience so we're
approaching like the place we're going
to do the afternoon you know landing
spot which is just kind of sky deck
overlooking the jungle and I wanted to
take my shoes off as I walked up this so
I just fucking did it I took my shoes
off didn't worry about the mosquitoes
and that felt great just feeling the
grass and the mud on my feet it was a
short walk so there wasn't any crazy
shit going on in the in the brush or
anything I had to worry about we get up
there and I go to lie down and I had
taken again I had taken the most watch
you might had taken at any point ever so
I'm more blasted than I have been the
whole trip because I got eight ounces
instead of sick and I go to lie down and
I'm pondering this idea of choice a lot
and fears and you know feeling pretty
good because everything that's happened
I was passed these tests and I see his
little ant crawling towards me to my
right hand side and I look like oh fuck
there's an ant coming and so I totally
broke my train of thought stood straight
up and then I look back that hat and i
just realized holy shit i just let that
little fucking aunt have the power over
me to make me sit up lose my train of
consciousness and completely move on his
behalf and it wasn't like a deadly
poison his aunt it was just an ant and
then I thought to myself how many other
these little things that are truly ants
in our existence fears worries
paranoia's relationships that you feel
crunchy about in a certain way or crunch
like something that's uncomfortable to
you in a situation or that you're
projecting and your simulator is worried
about these little things that went in
reality are no more than these ants
which are harmless cause you to make to
choose actions that aren't in your best
interest you know and we because we give
them power we give them the power over
us to make us move they do have power
and they could do just as good I mean
they can have a show you did it from
your fucking living room 12 years ago
and look at you today and if let's say
that they somehow co-opted us and we
sell out right there's some someone
somebody also replace Mike Jones he's
waiting is in austin texas you say
you're the number one but I've got some
statistics I've got the documents right
here and show you're a liar jank you're
a new world order puppet he seems like
he's out there where
for the people he's not working for the
people he went for MSNBC ladies and
gentlemen you don't get to MSNBC unless
you sell your soul to David Ickes
reptilians that was awesome I've never I
never heard you do that that's that was
amazing I've known that dude for a long
time Alex Jones in 1999 i did a DVD in
austin texas and alex jones and i put on
Bush masks I was a bush jr he was bush
senior and we we were these outfits and
ran around the Capitol and it was called
the live from the belly of the beast it
was right before bush senior got elected
and I've known him for even before then
I've known that guy for a long time my
theory is that Alex is a false flag
operation really yeah is that really a
real theory kind of i'm half kidding
half serious yeah well you say that
because you're trying to fuck with me
what are you trying to do right now is
co-op my mind I'm sitting here in Los in
taxes i'm smoking cigarettes i'm
drinking whiskey i'm getting fucking
crazy i'm trying to protect people from
the government there's black helicopters
their flight over my dodge charger
that's fucking funny Tom Rhodes don't
piss on st. that's not the bathroom yeah
that's not the bathroom he's in there
I've done that a lot having bingo has
caught me so many times trying to go
into the closet and a hotel room to take
a piss that you go well that's the
amount of times you've woken up and
found me how many times have had pissed
off my own shit I never knew about it
twat member I do it all the time the
humidity I guess I'm trying to marry who
told this story but somebody opened up
their drawer and they pissed on their
sock drawer they opened up they went to
their dresser and they pull their sock
drawer open and they just pissed in
there oh my god the fuck did you think
your sock drawer was the toilet I don't
know I'm sure you've done this dog peed
in the corner of Allah hotel room are we
talking about we saw you go through the
wrong door thinking y'all gonna win you
peed in the corner of a lot of hotel
know a few of them just being plastered
like you know ya could assign dinner he
thought I was there how many times
bingos caught me doing that versus how
many times she didn't wake up that I did
that and didn't know I did that that's
those extra two shots well
Lorraine says it's over Doug Stanhope
you say the fuck is I was plastered in
Ireland years ago and I went out the
room door I thought I was going to die
was just drunk and a half awake I just
needed to pee and then on the fucking
hallway naked I was banging on the door
my hand girlfriend get cummed what the
fuck are you doing out there i'm the
motherfucking door we already have this
on a podcast Hennigan did that right
there my manager and Henry Phillips both
have stories walking out thinking
they're going into the bathroom walking
out naked and the door shuts me them and
they're both naked in the fucking
hallway go and then you instantly become
John Ritter I've abyss here there's no
way that's not comedy you know what are
you very sober k how many people know I
don't have identification you do like a
20-year bid in a hotel you work in the
hotel for 20 years somic dudes coming
down naked how many dudes come down
naked in your entire career holding
their cock and balls is going believe
knives that's what I am Brian well he
went into a like a locker a housekeeping
door that was open grabbed a sheet or
whatever put it over his dick I walk
down to the hotel and they just gave
them a key he didn't say ID or anything
ideology is that I mean I I don't
remember who said it but it's it's the
enemy of free-thinking mm-hmm you you
get in these ideological clusters and
then anything outside of this thing
these predetermined patterns of behavior
that you've to subscribe to anything
becomes forbidden it becomes you can't
even entertain it you can't even
approach the idea I'm you see it with
everything you see with atheism you see
it with you see it with any isms with
feminism with the Men's Rights you see
it with with people who subscribe to the
right people subscribe to the left any
variables that don't fit into their
equation that they've already subscribed
to they don't want to be labeled as that
other side and any time they don't want
to be labeled they start ignoring any
evidence or any ideas that don't fit
within this really ridge
description that's exactly right I mean
that is you hit the nail on the head joe
i'm just weird exactly right where
people get locked into these ideological
paradigms and then from that point on
basically their perspective is modified
more by emotion and rationality more by
you know their feelings rather than real
information you're the only person
that's ever come in sat down and said oh
this is good i'm getting a cortisol rush
she said you getting a cortisol rush
from the feeling of about do apart
actually i could have gone a little more
detail but as we do yeah you know so
that feeling of anxiety you know that
like you get before you go on stage I
mean you're a comedian i'm sure i'm
currently familiar with that you
actually are expressing a chemical
called dane orphan and this is an
endogenous Kemel in your brain and it
binds to something called the kappa
opioid receptor it's kind of like the
counter of the endorphin which binds to
the MU opioid receptor so the and
orphans are the feel-good well its
nemesis is the dynorphin which is that
anxiety like feeling so but here's the
interesting part that anxiety like
feeling that you feel before you're you
know going to do something like you're
you know really that you care about or
that's kind of anxiety provoking for me
public speaking does it I get it right
before I'm going to do it you know give
a talk or something or do a podcast in
front of you know 500,000 people um so
that dynorphin binding to the kappa
opioid receptor what it does is it up
regulates the new opioid receptor so
that after you get that anxiety feeling
you have a better endorphin rush because
you up regulate the new up your
receptors which bind to the endorphins
to feel good ones and you actually
become sensitized to them so there's a
biological mechanism by which having
that anxiety actually does you good so
it's it's kind of like a stress at first
but then later on your you get you feel
better and you're more relaxed